are you aware of any other podcast in a
hot tub not yet not yet here I go where
the winners for the winners I love it
alright boom what's up everyone welcome
to simulation I'm your host Don sakya
and we are on-site in Boston
Massachusetts we are now speaking again
for our second show in the hot tub again
with dr. Rick Doblin the founder and
executive director of maps the
multidisciplinary Association for
psychedelic studies thank you so much
it's great to join you for this series
of hot tub interviews this one the PG
version with bathing suits I spent a lot
of time editing the first version
because we needed to make sure that
there was no lower body visibilities
because we came in naked this time we
are in bathing suits to make editing
much easier and the PG version as Rick
said and Rick oh my gosh okay
the 33 years that Rick has put his life
blood sweat and tears into psychedelic
studies you can watch our first episode
together the links in the bio where we
talk about that 33 year journey and what
has really went into understanding how
psychedelics can inspire a sense of
unity and help a lot with some of the
big issues that we see today with 10
million people have PTSD in the United
States
Rick's currently in Phase three of
clinical trials with MDMA psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy very important
yeah so so important and we'll have you
break that down again for us or as a
refresher and they're in phase 3 right
now they were awarded the breakthrough
breakthrough therapy designation by the
FDA you know for the most promising
drugs yes and that means you actually
got to work with the FDA on road mapping
out how this study is going to play out
in Phase three
yeah how we're gonna spend the twenty
seven million dollars so for the next
couple years that we've raised all from
donations for Phase three research
in huge shout out to all of the humans
that have helped contribute 200 yeah we
just did a year-end fundraising we had
over 1600 people donate yep oh I wonder
yeah great and we promoted it to trying
to get more people it worked great we
raised over four hundred thousand
dollars shockingly
yep yep yeah just like that yeah and now
so it's aiming to figure out how to
spend the twenty seven million on Phase
three now and there's so um so let's
break this down so okay everyone there's
you had radical success in Phase two of
clinical trials in Phase two you saw
that 68% of your hundred and seven yeah
patients experienced no no longer PTSD
symptoms
well that was at the 12-month follow-up
okay so the way the research has done we
compared everybody at baseline then we
get the treatment
some people get MDMA with either with
cyclic there some people let me say it
again
some people get therapy with either
low-dose MDMA or no MDMA and then some
people get therapy with full dose MDMA
and then we compare the two groups and
so for the FDA the measurement two
months after the last experimental
session it's what's called the final
outcome measure and that's what the FDA
is going to look at to approve the drug
between the control group and the
experimental group the 12-month
follow-up is what we're doing more for
insurance companies to try to help them
see that it's durable that they spend
all this money on this short-term
intervention but it lasts and so that's
where the 68% figure comes from the
two-thirds more than two-thirds no
longer have PTSD at the end of the 12
months 12 months it's around 61% at the
two-month follow-up you but what that
shows is that people have learned how to
process painful emotions yes and that
they continue to do that on their own
after the treatment so that people keep
getting better after the treatment is
over it's not like a traditional
treatment with let's say SSRIs from PTSD
where it controls some symptoms you
still generally a PTSD if you stop
taking the medicine and problems come
back because it was just symptom early
yeah we're trying to get to the heart of
the problem which is these fearful
memories that torment people and help
them process them in a different way and
so that's the beautiful part is that
people keep getting better on their own
after we're done with the treatment yes
and so that this is also so important as
Rick is bringing this up this is not
just a single mm mdma-assisted
psychotherapy and then you're out the
door this is 12 total assisted sessions
no 3 3 a 3 with a 3 with MDMA and then
about 9:00 or so without well it's
actually 3 MDMA sessions day-long
sessions you know eight hours with an
overnight stay for people to rest and
then there's 12 90-minute non drug
psychotherapy sessions God so there's
three before the first MDMA session for
preparation and to develop what we call
it or what the field calls the
therapeutic alliance the trust between
the therapist and the patient that
they're going to be safe that they're
going to be okay yes and we have two
therapists a male-female team yes so
it's not just one therapist it's two
we're evolving to the point where it
will be one experienced therapist and
then a student because it's very
expensive to have two therapists for one
person but if we can make it so that
it's just really paying for one and the
other gets minimal payment because
they're getting hours towards licensure
and we're training the next generation
of therapists so it's three MDMA
sessions three to five weeks apart and
then three non drug psychotherapy
sessions for preparation and then three
for integration after each MDMA
experimental session or or for the
control group the therapy takes place
without MDMA so in phase 3 there is no
low dose 70 ma it's either therapy with
inactive placebo or therapy with
yes and again it's this thus the
psychedelic assisted psychotherapy
component is so crucial that there is a
male and female psychotherapist out
there with the with the patient and if
you want to take a look at some of the
partial testimonials we have a phase two
studies there was a veteran that had
severe suicidal tendencies and then went
through your face too and then had no
suicidal yeah inclinations whatsoever at
work so this is it happened with Manny
and we and he was a veteran that had
previously attempted suicide several
times yes so we don't exclude people
that have never tried suicide so some
people might say that's kind of
dangerous to include people in our
research but what we're trying to do is
work with the most difficult cases
yeah because MDMA is controversial and
so if we can show that it works with the
most difficult cases that will help get
it approved yeah and then the other
thing I want to mention is that people
often go into sort of regress states
that a lot of people that have PTSD have
had earlier experiences of trauma in
addition to whatever it was that tipped
them over into PTSD and we don't know
people's history as well as you know
they have it stored in their minds
sorting their bodies there's a book by
Bessel van der Kolk the doctor who's the
expert on PTSD who's the principal
investigator of our Boston site and his
book is called the body keeps the score
yes so we have this view of our
therapeutic process is that there's this
inner wisdom that's like I'm glad you're
going to the neuroscience and psychology
of things because we wanted to make sure
to give a heavy touch on this oh good
yeah okay yeah so like the storage of
the of the traumatic stress needs to be
processed yeah and what happens with
PTSD is that PTSD changes people's
brains and the way it changes people's
brains it's like a groove you know
in your mind that patterns that
developed and so there's a reduction of
activity in the prefrontal cortex where
we think rationally and put things in
context whose people are emotionally
irrationally triggered there's an
increase in activity in the amygdala
which is where we process fear and
there's a decrease also in hippocampus
where we process memories into long-term
storage
so PTSD changes people's brains and MDMA
changes people's brains also but in the
opposite way it's like almost like the
perfect drug for PTSD so in healthy
volunteers taking MDMA into brain scans
MRI scanners it increases activity in
the frontal cortex with prefrontal
cortex so people can think more
rationally it decreases activity in the
amygdala so that people aren't so
reactive from fear from these powerful
memories of trauma and it increases
activity between the hippocampus and the
amygdala so memories can be moved out of
kind of the short-term storage where
it's always seeming like it's about to
happen yes or it's always still
happening or every sound bring somebody
back to the traumatic experience and so
MDMA facilitates the recall of the
memories and we have better memory
recall under MDMA than people have
without MDMA so the memory of the trauma
people have a clear memory for more of
it and the problem is that when you have
memories that are unconscious or
unaccessible they control our moods our
immune system control our behaviors
we're not even aware of them so the fact
that memory is increased under the
influence of MDMA
is really really helpful and then the
fact that this hippocampus amygdala
connection is strengthened that permits
these memories that emerge into
consciousness to be then stored in the
past they're not always happening so
that then what happens is the next time
somebody brings back this memory and
it's called memory reconsolidation that
memory is assembled from different
versions of the brain the episodic
memory the emotional memory but when we
have the experience the memory we have
to recreate the memory rewrite the
memory and so basically what we're
trying to do is have a better recall for
the trauma but replace the fear emotion
with an emotion of peacefulness and a
recognition that it was in the past
yeah and so it's called the you know
emotional memory and episodic memory yes
so we're replacing the emotional memory
with a different emotion because when
they recalled the trauma they weren't
feeling the terror now MDMA also
increases hormones particularly oxytocin
and prolactin and these are the hormones
of nursing mothers that love oxytocin
has been called the love hormone and so
that creates a sense of safety a sense
of connection because people with PTSD
have lost trust or isolated and the MDMA
facilitates this pro-social emotions and
activities and you may have heard or
your listeners may have heard they were
about to hear from about it now about
the study in octopus the octopi so
neuroscientist at Johns Hopkins was
interested in the MDMA and pro-social
behavior and she wanted to do a study
giving MDMA document because humans have
occupied I've urged evolutionary about
200 million years ago and I try up
different kind of brains than human
brain
and so the experiment was puts it also
has three hearts there's some crazy
things going yeah there's a lot of
neurons and in there they're very smart
yeah they're very smart and so the
experiment was a little bit like us in
the hot dog so what they do is that they
have a three chambers in the first
chamber as the octopus in this in the
center chamber is the activist I've on
either side or two different chambers
with doors into them one of them is an
inanimate object a ball in a birdcage so
you can see through it that the ball
can't beat me lunging and then the other
chamber is another octopi and also in
this sort of bird cage so they can't
move either so normally what happens is
that the octopus will spend more time
with the inanimate object than with the
other octopus whether it's a male
octopus and a female octopus are the
only time mark the [ __ ] are more
social is during mating season mm-hmm
all right so then what they do is
they've they did a little it took a
little bit of calculations and
experimenting to figure it out but they
put MDMA in water and so so imagine that
we're at octopus and they dunk them in
this bath for like ten minutes and
during which time octopi absorb symptom
and I would like to explain we have not
dumped MDMA this hot tub what that's
right although that would have been a
waste of MDMA otherwise we would have
been naked we were not here PG all right
so then when they put this MDMA dosed
octopus in the chamber it turns out that
they spend more time with the other
octopus than with the inanimate object
so there's something fundamentally
physiologically going on with MDMA
pre-language that's really deep about
connections yeah about socialization and
so you know one thing that the FDA is
requiring us to do once we finish the
study in adults and assuming it goes
well we have been required to do phase
four studies so phase four is post
approval and we're being required to do
study in adolescent
yes initially with 12 to 17 year olds
and then of that works with 7 to 11 year
olds now these are kids that have been
traumatized trauma as I said changes
your brains you know some people have
heard well we got to protect kids
developing brains but when they've been
traumatized their brains are developing
abnormally and MDMA can potentially
restore a more normal processing and
help people overcome the kids so we will
find that out and the fact that it works
in octave want to be you know pro-social
makes me think that this therapy will
work in adolescence and even younger
kids are traumatized even without a lot
of verbal psychotherapy but just
creating a safe space so that's
physiologically a bit of a story on how
empty may actually works the other thing
for the more scientifically minded
people that are listening I want to
explain about a methodology issue
related to phase 3 and that's how do you
do a double-blind study with a drug like
MDMA which generally if you've been told
that you're gonna receive a placebo or
you're gonna receive an MDMA bill and
you receive the placebo very few people
think oh this is really the MDMA and if
you've got the placebo very few and if
you get the MDMA very few people say oh
nothing happened so how do you do a
double-blind study you know with a drug
like MDMA and so a lot of my
dissertation at Harvard the Kenny school
government was on this problem how do
you solve the double-blind issue and as
it turned out I thought I had solved the
problem if you use an inactive placebo
you know it won't work that often to
fool people if you use active placebos
like amphetamine or tranquilizers people
will think oh something's happening but
both amphetamines and tranquilizers will
make our therapy less effective you know
when you tranquilize somebody they need
to be emotionally available and when you
give them feta means to be with PTSD if
you look at the drugs that people with
PTSD take to avoid their problems it's
alcohol
it's opiates you know it's sometimes
other drugs but it's not they don't do
stimulants because that activates them
and doesn't reduce the fear so giving
those kind of drugs first off the
therapist would be able to tell the
difference anyway and the patient's
might be fooled initially but it makes
the therapy more complicated less
effective and so the solution that I
came up with was low doses of the test
drug and so one group gets therapy with
low-dose MDMA the other group gets
therapy with full dose MDMA and then
there's more confusion and I thought the
challenge was going to be to find the
dose of MDMA that was low enough to make
people think something was happening but
not high enough to be therapeutic okay
because if it's therapeutic then you're
a difficult time finding a difference
between the two groups so we tested 25
milligrams 30 milligrams 40 milligrams
75 milligrams 100 milligrams 125
milligrams in 150 yeah and what we
discovered to my surprise was that where
it turns therapeutic we found at 75
milligrams so the group that got 75
milligrams did very very well this was
in our study of veterans firefighters
and police officers even a little better
than the group that got 125 interesting
but the group that had 125 had more
higher depression scores okay but it's
definitely 75 was effective
remarkably so and so the lower doses of
MDMA though did produce more blinding so
I was right about that but they they
acted more like an amphetamine and then
they made people more anxious they
stimulated them but they didn't reduce
their fear and so actually people found
it uncomfortable and while they still
got better a little bit they didn't get
as much better as the group that just
got therapy without any MDMA at all so
when we went to the FDA for our final
meeting in what's called the special
protocol assessment process where we
negotiate every aspect of the design and
try to come to agreement with FDA and if
you do then you get this agreement
letter and that means the FDA is legally
bound to approve the drug if you get
statistically significant evidence of
efficacy and if no new safety problems
arise in Sibiu tens of millions of
people have taken MDMA we know the
safety profile very well over a thousand
people have taken it I think over 1,300
people have taken it infinitely research
already mostly by other people mostly
healthy volunteers yeah so we've got
this moving towards this agreement and
the biggest hang of it the final end was
how do we do this double-blind study
yeah so I opened the meeting and I said
one of my favorite quotes is that and I
thought it was from William James but it
really is from an early president of
Harvard William James started the
psychology program at Harvard is the
founder of American psychology
psychology building at Harvard is named
after William James so I got it wrong
but the quote I got right and so the
quote was remember about the century ago
and president of Harvard said never
forget there's always a Harvard man on
the wrong side of every issue yeah and
so I said this one it's me I thought I
solved the problem but I didn't because
I could not anticipate that these low
doses would have an anti therapeutic
effect so I went to the FDA and I said
we'll do whatever you want you know you
can choose blinding yeah
or but that's gonna make it easier for
us to find a difference between a
therapy with full dose MDMA and
there be with this Lotus so I propose
that they new therapy with inactive
emblem MDMA versus therapy with full
dose MDM okay and I said we do whatever
they want yeah and so the FDA said based
on the known problems of a double-blind
and also the double-blind doesn't work
as often as people think it does even
with SSRIs and other drugs there's side
effect profiles that people can tell the
difference that the therapist and
researchers can tell the difference so
the double-blind doesn't it's not as
theoretically effective as it seems
on its surface so that so the the
there's Bob temple who's the the sort of
old wise man at the FDA he's been at the
FDA since 1972 he's head of their office
of science policy he came to the final
meeting good and he said he agreed with
us and so we've accepted that there are
going to be challenges to the
double-blind but that this is the best
way to do the design here's what FDA
said was in situations like that and and
in general research there's two main
ways to eliminate experimenter bias not
only did Bob time to say that's the way
we should do the study but then when we
presented it to the European Medicines
Agency
they agreed with that so the European
study will be designed in a similar way
and because of that the European
Medicines Agency will accept our US data
so while it's 27 million to make MDMA
into a medicine for FDA it's only going
to be nine million to make it into a
medicine throughout Europe great yes I
never thought about it so deeply that
the design of the double-blind
controlled study is what's so important
to make sure that the acts are actually
working out yeah what they said though
is that the other ways that we eliminate
experimenter bias are first off random
assignment so there have been some
studies that where you take people who
have a problem and then it didn't work
for them and then you say who wants to
volunteer for this new treatment yeah
and then you compare them against the
success rates of the
the normal treatment but that's that
right because you're getting people that
are especially motivated so they're more
interested in getting better than those
that didn't volunteer for this new
experiments before they have less fears
of the treatment so you need random
assignment means everybody is
volunteering to be in the same exact
design either to get MDMA or silicide or
placebo and then you randomly assign
them so that's a very important part of
eliminating biases everybody's similarly
motivated then the other part is how you
do the measures of the outcomes and you
can't have the therapists measure it
because they're biased they want it to
work and so what you end up doing is you
have a team of independent raters and
we've got our team mostly it's been
trained by the Boston veterans
administration and they developed the
measure called the caps the clinician
administered PTSD scale well they're
still used all over the world across the
world and it's been revised so we're
using the caps v which is the latest
version of it and so we have this
rotating group of around 20 Raiders that
will be assigned to whichever person
needs to be evaluated next and they'll
all be done by telemedicine and so we're
trying to break the connection between
the Raiders either being the therapist
but also knowing where the person is in
the process of therapy is it the
baseline is that after the first MDMA
after the second after the third is it
the one-year follow-up the two-month oh
so that's how we're going to do it so
we've had to come up with a very
sophisticated way of doing the ratings
and that's the approach to eliminating
investigator bias now the other thing I
want to share is that the double-blind
does sometimes work and so we have a
protocol from the FDA approved by the
DEA where we can give MDMA to therapists
as part of their training and so we're
training them for working on phase 3
studies where people will either get
MDMA or a placebo and so it's basically
a five-day program where they come in on
the first day they get oriented then the
next day they either get MDMA or they
get a placebo for an eight-hour
the recession then the day after that is
for integration and rest and then
there's a switch crawl the crossover and
then they get whatever they didn't get
the first time and then there's another
day of integration and so the so we're
preparing them to deal with how do you
work with somebody for eight hours when
they didn't get the MDMA yeah and that
gives people the experience of MDMA
because as we move to mainstream we're
gonna work with a lot of people that
didn't come from the psychedelic
Underground that are from traditional
therapy worlds you know we need a legal
way to give them MDMA to prepare them to
be more effective therapists so we've
had two times of so far we've done this
for about over 60 people from all over
the world we do trained in this way you
know we've had two times where people
were so enthusiastic these were both
people that have never done MDMA and now
they had so wanted to get him he may the
first time because then you also you
have more days to talk with the
therapist about having more days to
integrate editor sure so it turned out
that they both of these people were so
relieved because I'm the first time they
got MDMA and they went through this
really profound experience working on
levels of trauma going back to childhood
with emotional release with crying this
was fantastic now both of these were
psychiatrists and they had watched a
week-long part of our training program
as a week-long program residential
program watching videotapes of actual
therapy sessions yes going over our
treatment manual and talking about our
therapeutic approach so they'd already
seen that they'd already seen a lot of
people doing MDMA through these videos
so they were super thrilled to get MDMA
the first time they have these profound
experiences and they persuaded the
therapist now these are experienced
therapists that have worked with a lot
of PTSD patients 100% sure that it was
really MDMA and they were a hundred
percent sure it was really MDMA and then
they have their integration they do more
work and then they were preparing for
the third day to be an easy day getting
the placebo just listening to music and
having kind of relaxed time and so one
of them after about an hour and 15
minutes or so during this easy session
he just
stop talking and he didn't talk for
hours yeah and he was stunned because it
turned out that he had gotten the
placebo the first time Wow and that now
that he had the MDMA he was just
speechless and at one point he turned to
the books on that bookshelf and he
pointed at the books and they went like
no and then he pointed to his heart like
it's all in the feelings the books the
knowledge the intellectual knowledge
didn't prepare me at all it's not in the
books it's in the heart heart and both
of those people that were a hundred
percent sure that persuaded experienced
therapists that were a hundred percent
sure they had the MDMA when they really
had the placebo both were psychiatrists
so it's not to say that the the placebo
methodology doesn't work at all and it's
just astonishing and what very
psychiatrist said afterwards is that
once they could recover their ability to
talk that there was an effortless and
deeper flow between the conscious and
the unconscious beautiful with the MDMA
that they realized how a part of their
mind was leading them to have these
experiences and trying to manufacture
this MDMA like state so what that points
out first off is that you can learn this
MDMA state that's why this is
fundamentally different than traditional
pharmacal therapy where you get a drug
every day for months or years or your
lifetime we only give them to make
people three times and the integration
process is about helping them learn how
to act like they're on MDMA how to
process emotions even without the MDMA
so the difference between recreational
use and therapeutic use is recreational
use people are like I'm going to take
this drug I'm going to go out and party
and have a good time and then when it's
over it's over
but therapy it's like I'm going to take
this drug I'm going to go into this
therapeutic set
in a process the full range of emotions
not just happy emotion yes and I'm going
to try to learn and bring back and
integrate so I can do this on my own
without the drug exactly so even though
people think Oh MDMA is a drug it's a
party drug it's a schedule and drug we
actually have an anti-drug therapeutic
approach to help people prompt them with
some deep profound MDMA experiences so
they don't either drug anymore exactly
now that's also the orientation from a
nonprofit pharmaceutical that's right if
we are for-profit we're like oh my god
you're gonna have to take this drug once
a month for the rest of your life or at
least for a year or two or you know so
it's really remarkable and I think it
also points to the fact that MDMA
because it's not that fundamentally
different from the way we normally
process feelings and emotions in a way
we can recognize it but it's it is
fundamentally different in the sense of
a reduction of fear and a new way it's
profoundly different yet profoundly
similar so it's easier for people to
integrate MDMA experiences that
ayahuasca or psilocybin or LSD or other
classic psychedelics where there's ego
dissolution where it's a new you know
different kind of consciousness MDMA is
more rational consciousness with a
profound emotional effect and say that
that's I think what contributes to its
therapeutic efficacy yeah Rick is
pointing out a couple really key things
here the first thing that he's pointing
out that I think is so key is that the
difficulty of figuring out how to design
these trials properly and then also
because this is now going to be
happening for all of the other that this
is now going on with LSD in Switzerland
this is aiming to be done with ibogaine
and ayahuasca and cannabis and so many
other side psilocybin as well so so now
what Rick is doing is he's helping lay a
foundation of clinical trial design yeah
for the next psychedelics that come in
and be able to tweak and play with this
in ways that make sense yeah and that's
first this major crucial point that
you're pointing out which
so happy you brought up the second
crucial thing that I'm that I'm hearing
you bring up that's so important to
recognize that there's this wide
spectrum of traumatic experiences that
happen any anything from actual abuse
and violence and rape and and and fun
war all the way to maybe somewhat
classified as a more or less abusive and
potentially trauma and and maybe that is
someone passing maybe that is someone
that is the long grief prolonged grief
on something yeah and so with with work
or with family or with whatever what
have us in this conversation that that
that trauma to be neurophysiological eyx
in integrated into our being most
effectively through a psychedelic as as
a psychotherapy experience can not only
help with ten million people that have
PTSD in the u.s. but people around the
world that have had humans are just on
we have traumatic experiences in our
lives and just to be able to properly
integrate them and move forward is so
crucial yeah well there's
multi-generational trauma that permits
these conflicts to go on generation
after generation and we're learning more
about epigenetics how you know certain
anxiety levels things can be passed from
generation to generation not so much
through changing genes but through
changing which genes are turned on and
off but the other thing I'd like to say
is that for every human being who's
alive right now there's an enormous
background level of trauma because of
climate change and global warming and
the oceans warming and the extinctions
of animals and the number of nuclear
weapons and biological weapons and if
you read the paper
you know the increasing polarization in
the United States and this came memory
after the Cold War yeah yeah so there's
that transgenerational trauma is until
we find that sense of unity with each
other and with our planet and with our
own selves inside when we won't be able
to train
send the transgenerational trauma that
it's occurring yeah so I think this
points to another issue which is the
whole example of and the historical
experience we've had with global
promotion that we're talking about from
a strategic point of view working with
the worst case is the hardest cases that
people that are suffering the most that
are disabled with PTSD there's roughly a
million veterans receiving disability
payments from the Veterans
Administration for disabling PTSD at a
cost of somewhere in the neighborhood of
20 billion dollars a year to the VA for
all and we've not got a penny from the
VA for doing this resource yeah there's
another 600,000 or so veterans disabled
from anxiety depression and other mental
disorders for another 10 plus billion
dollars a year so it's an enormous
problem for the VA it's an enormous
problem for society yes and I think what
we see is that politicians particularly
populist authoritarian politicians
manipulate people's fears and anxieties
against the other and they do that
because people are insecure and worried
and here's a convenient scapegoat and so
I think this idea of initially for
strategic reasons working through
science working through medicine trying
to help patient populations that are
highly valued by the mainstream society
like veterans and first responders and
women who've been sexually abused yes
that we are able to bring a
controversial drug forward at a time of
need
but that overall the long-term vision is
that we move from a criminal justice
approach to a public health Roche to
treating people's interactions with
drugs and I'd say the fundamental
problem of the criminal justice approach
is that it invests drugs with certain
properties these are the schedule one
drugs these are the bad drugs these are
the drugs you should never take these
are the drugs that always have risks and
no benefits and these are okay the drugs
you can take from Big Pharma or you know
echo alcohol Yamma and of course they
have side effects but we'll overlook
them so we invest properties and drugs
and then of course the drug war has been
used
to demonize minorities too you know here
we hear about all these hordes of drug
dealers coming through the Mexican
border when you know walls wall how this
was your initial actually study into
psychedelics was discovering that it was
a ban on psychedelics due to the sense
of unity in the 60s that this inspired
yeah I think there's two different
narratives for the sixth year one was
that all these people took psychedelics
and a lot of them were unprepared and
people had frightening experiences and
they went to emergency rooms or they had
a schizophrenic break or they committed
suicide or jumped out of a wooden Tower
you know stared at the Sun and went
blind person that was a completely
made-up story but this idea that it was
because of the excesses it was because
of the problems with the use of
psychedelics that they were all
criminalized the other narrative that I
think is more accurate is that it's not
about when psychedelics went wrong it's
about psychedelics going right exactly
and this is part of Good Friday and your
investigation into that and figure and
and following up with people 20 years 25
25 years later
yeah and seeing the profound shifts
still yeah and people yeah and so the
different idea experiment was 1962 done
by Timothy Leary was the faculty sponsor
Walter Mackey was the investigator he
was a minister and a doctor and as we
went into this in detail already on the
first one but but but the continuation
of this of the school of thought of the
psychedelics going right and then being
throttled well but okay so going right
means people sensing that we're all
connected that we're all connected okay
now this also happened during the 60s
when we were going to the moon yeah and
so we started seeing pictures of the
Earth from the moon and you don't see
borders you see this one globe were all
together yes so this fundamental sense
of unity reduces people's fear of the
other yes can you access to the other
and we appreciate differences because
we're fundamentally the same yes we're
difference in very minor ways yes and we
can and I think if we look at religions
like languages like there's all these
four languages that different cultures
have developed to communicate to each
other but it's a difficult thing and
they're different the different
languages emphasize different things you
think in different ways but it's hard to
say English is better than German and
German is better than French and French
is better than Spanish you know or
French is the only way to communicate
really all these other languages are
invalid so I think religions are like
that they emerge from cultures they have
certain cultural references but they're
all about this sense of connection of
spirituality they all have them your
honor yeah they all vote so I think that
we will appreciate other people's
religions as different flavors yes
different cultural histories yes and so
what we're talking about with this kind
of global spirituality is not the loss
of individuality or people's tone
dividual allegedly it's just a
surrendering of these truth claims that
this is the one right religion yeah this
is the only way to spirituality or
heaven or however you want to say the
one the one right way is earth is
everyone here on earth is all sisters
and brothers moving forward and elected
so I think if we look at some of the
things that developed in the 60s
psychedelics were connected to the
anti-war movement too in Vietnam they
were connected to people that were
involved in the environmental movement
and the civil rights movement in the
women's rights movement and so it's
psychedelics going right it's
psychedelics having this consciousness
experience of unity and connection that
then has implications for people for how
they see the world and how they act in
the world and that was causing people to
challenge the status quo and that's what
led to the backlash you know it used to
be that it was like the Copernican
revolution where the earth was the
center of the university oh that's like
our ego are you here of the center of
the universe right okay and then there
was the switch to the Sun the Earth
revolves around the Sun you know that we
revolve around the big self the
collective unconscious the history of
mankind all of the developments all the
millions of people that develop the
languages that we use so I think it's
that switch the Copernican switch from
what's the center of the universe from
our ego yielding this but the ego
doesn't go away the earth doesn't go
away because we revolve around the Sun
so I think we can
dress the fears of the fundamentalists
and say we can enrich your spirituality
and you don't have to believe this is
the only way and everybody else's
infidels and they have to kill them
those are power games not spiritual
games and so I think it's that crisis of
psychedelics in the 60s being connected
to people challenging the state's woman
finished the one thought about
Ehrlichman he said in an interview later
in the 70s before he died that the two
main enemies of Nixon and the Nixon
White House were civil rights and
hippies you know civil rights activists
and hipping soon and he said we if we
could criminalize the drugs that they
used opiates for a lot of
african-americans and psychedelics and
marijuana for the hippies we criminalize
those drugs we can disrupt their
meetings we can go after their leaders
we can stick them in jail and he said
did we know we were exaggerating the
risks of these drugs of course we did so
I think that the narrative of what
happened in the 60s there were problems
with psychedelics going wrong but it was
really psychedelic going right so as we
introduce psychedelics back into the
culture now people have already seen
after 50 years that most of those people
that did Sega dokes when they young did
not go live on a commune in grow
soybeans you know they became part of
society like Steve Jobs founding Apple
absolutely and so I think that's the
that that didn't happen and so now we
really have to be careful about the
other problems of psychedelics going
wrong yeah and that's why we have it's
not psychedelics it's psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy yeah you know we
hit the bottom you did you did such a
good job at making a comparison to the
Copernican revolution our soon our ego
as our self we'll take a back seat to
the collective but we will still be able
to be individuals yes rock together so
ego death is the wrong term yeah yeah
correct doesn't wonderful one can the
the the death latent latent well one can
oscillate between yeah do between the
lowest ego states in the highest yeah
etcetera so and so as you as you speak
about this it seems as though we will be
we're getting to that point finally
where we are slowly transcending the
older infrastructures of civilization
and moving forth into more potentially
prosperous unity destruction this is the
struggle hopefully this is the struggle
I think we can see the rise of Trump and
the rise of populism as a reaction
against that and it's it's very
interesting to to think about how to
properly in really dose up on love
across the world first yeah because
there you can't just go okay no borders
and then the next day because there's
still people that haven't point dosed up
on love and a lot alike and so one needs
to then properly ensure somehow through
trust based protocols that everyone on
earth or a lot of people on earth are
dosed up on that true love then make a
deeper more unity infrastructure made
available to people as a transition and
that's why we need to go beyond medicine
Beyond and end prohibition so there's
billions that's right people can have
these kind of experiences voluntarily if
they want to yes and I think the more
that they see the outcomes for people
that have done this the more people will
be open to it
yes right and Rick again is coming
bringing us to the public health
approach to these things
and and you're right that as we bring up
the public health approach and bringing
in involving psychedelics in the public
health approach so so we we bring we
bring we bring psychedelics up in the
public health approach in psychedelic
assist psychotherapy and all threats and
yet all drugs in general in in
integrating art our traumas are in
transgenerational traumas until this
point that makes it easier for us to get
to the point of unity through a public
health approach to assisted
psychotherapy I love that yeah and I
just say that Robert Mueller who is the
assistant secretary-general
nations in the 80s who wrote a book III
called New Genesis shaping of global
spirituality and that his fundamental
thesis is we need global spirituality
and his book was beautiful but he didn't
say anything about psychedelics so I
wrote him a letter and to my shock he
wrote me back and we started
communicating because I said you didn't
say I think about psychedelics yeah I
told him about a good Friday experiment
and and then he came along and he
started helping us bring back
psychedelic research but I think that's
this theory that you might say it's a
bunch of hippies and a hot tub you know
yeah yeah but it's not it comes from the
Assistant Secretary General United
Nations that's right that this kind of
global spirituality is where we need to
move and then a lot of the conflicts
between nations are religious conflicts
and so we need this global spirituality
that's right and how we develop that as
the challenge of the human species right
now it is yeah it is so well said this
is the main challenge the human species
is prospering together moving forward
yeah Rick I want to make sure we touch
on this okay we are moving toward a an
era of figuring out how to administer
these most effectively into the world
and there's more and more pop up sort of
happening for example you taught us
about this in the last session that that
the University of Mississippi has
monopoly on the cannabis then that DEA
said okay fine that's done in 2016 yeah
and so now it's open
opened up the doors to know okay so I'm
so glad that you brought this up so
everything you said up to that last
point that it's opened up stuff is right
so in August 12 2016 DEA put something
in the Federal Register saying we're
gonna end the monopoly yeah on DEA
license marijuana because the FDA is a
federal rate agency and it can only work
with federally legal marijuana so even
though with all these states that they
have marijuana that's of high quality
and better even than the product that's
grown at the University of Mississippi
we can't use it in FDA studies and the
marijuana that comes from NIDA it's only
for research not for commercial sales as
a phase-three must be with the same drug
that you want to market yes so this
monopoly started in 1960
I think we're going to be able to end it
in the next six months but what happen
is once the DEA put this announcement in
the Federal Register that was in August
of 2016 then in November Trump got
elected yeah
and trumpet in attorney General Sessions
yeah and he is like a troglodyte back in
the olden days dinosaur and he said no
to marijuana so roughly 26 applications
that he is blocked for now for the court
up how there's a zoo we may see you
there in general there's multiple people
in the Senate that are on our side and
we're about to either launch a lawsuit
you know got an application from law
cranker and you miss hammer so I do over
the next six months that marijuana will
become federally there will be federally
legal marijuana processors private
producers that could make it into a
medicine and are going need to make the
but the flower exactly in a sheep form
and it will become generic after three
years after we make it yeah and so I'm
totally in favor of all sorts of
pharmaceutical companies taking the
marijuana plants slicing and dicing
making extracts making non-smoking
delivery systems and drops and sprays
and topicals and edibles all those kind
of stuff but I want the plant the flower
to be a medicine also and it will be the
least expensive medicine as a check on
all the prices that all these more
profit people will charge this is so
important that where we're making sure
to highlight this is that the United
States is actually giving up a 30-plus
billion dollars in medicinal marijuana
market across the world to Canada Israel
United Kingdom etc and Netherlands and
what we see is you were told us about
this last time that Israel is now down
to 14 dollars an ounce like 60 cents a
gram of really high quality cannabis
trim buttons trimmed buds and the way
that we can then take this extremely low
price if we can do this right in the
United States if we can really quickly
move the ball forward with cannabis we
can then start testing it for PTSD with
veterans we can really start moving yes
the ball forward in that yeah although I
would say that we are just now finishing
our first study with PTSD with
cannabis for PTSD and veterans we got
2.1 million dollars from the state of
Colorado from marijuana taxes and now's
the first government money which is
think yeah us yeah and the state used
marijuana from Mississippi from NIDA and
in Michigan get the yeah you taught us
about yes so so let me just say that
that the the project that we've just
finished is 76 treatment resistant
chronic severe PTSD patients with all
veterans and we've just the data lock
will be February 8th coming right up and
then we will analyze the data at the end
of February and then decide do we need
to do more phase 2 studies more phase 3
studies but we have finished in it the
results we can't say but one was a group
that got CBD one got teetsi one got
marijuana with THC and CBD event one was
it to Seba so we're very excited about
moving forward with the marijuana
project as well so what happened in
Michigan is Rob Campea who is was who
was the founder and the executive
director of the Marijuana Policy Project
they've had a big role in a lot of the
different state legalization efforts
Colorado and others and they work it
into their nature yeah so they put in
the Michigan a little tiny sentence or
two that says that if Michigan
legalization passes there has to be 20
million dollars a year for two years
better for veterans and to deal with
veterans suicide and it has to go to
nonprofits or academic researchers not
for-profit companies and it passed that
beam so we got to do more things like
now then there's been various people
inside Michigan have been saying talking
bad about maps like they don't want maps
together maps is going to take all the
money away from Michigan and take it out
of state or we're going to transfer the
money to psychedelic research so I wrote
a document for Michigan State
Legislators yeah
legislatures because there was an effort
both in the before the the new
legislature came in in the lame-duck
session to change the initiative and
they were trying to change this 20
million a year for two years but they
were unsuccessful in your links
and what we've indicated is that we're
willing to do whatever amount of
research they want to do in Michigan but
it's not the smartest because the
initiative was because twenty veterans a
day are committing suicide
yeah and marijuana can be helpful so if
we just try to do the study inside
Michigan it'll take longer to recruit
all the subjects so we're gonna try to
have many sites in Michigan but sites
all over there now again the legislature
has to come up with the procedures
they're not gonna have money for a year
or so until they actually start selling
marijuana and collecting the taxes but
that's very hopeful side future yeah so
the other way to break the monopoly is
through importation but so far there's
no the Israelis wanted to export and
President Trump called President
Netanyahu and said block it which he did
that was about six months ago so now the
Israelis of the parliament has passed
again another bill approving export the
none of the Canadian companies have yet
been willing to export flowers so right
now we have no ability to import from
around the world but that's another way
to break the monopoly and if we do then
it's utterly senseless to have them
prohibitions against domestic production
if we can go into drug development
research with imported supplies all
we're doing is hurting Americans by
keeping this exact provision in place
exactly and we see countries like Canada
making cannabis on their on their public
stock exchange billions billions of
dollars already the United States needs
to play catch-up we've talked about that
with Steve DeAngelo and a couple other
global leaders on our show yeah I'm in
the space so really looking forward to
that now
cannabis is one of many other subject
areas okay so there's a couple other
sites psychedelic assist psychotherapy
is going on
there's LSD there's ibogaine there's
ayahuasca
there's several psilocybin and this is
all for the compassionate use to deal
with anxiety
this little siphon is for cocaine
addiction for alpha so we there's an
MDMA study in England for MDMA for
alcoholics on the theory that trauma is
what drives people to run away from
their problems into drug abuse so there
is a lot of work in the treatment of a
okay with with psilocybin for tobacco
addiction for alcoholism for cocaine
that's crucial so addiction and then
there's the end of life as well and
dealing with that really well
yeah obsessive compulsive disorder
there's been some we're starting a new
study with eating disorders MDMA for
eating disorders and obsessive
compulsive yeah Wow
so we're bridging even Steve even
couples therapy although we've done that
in the form of PTSD research there's a
technique called cognitive behavioral
conjoint therapy can joint meaning
couple or dyads where one member has
PTSD but it affects the relationship and
so we're working with the people candace
Monson and Anne Wagner there now with
Ryerson University in Toronto and we've
been able to get permission to give both
members of the couple MDMA and it's been
tremendous and so you have some measures
of the relationship strength but the
primary outcome measure was the PTSD of
the person with PTSD in the dyad or the
couple but couples therapy would be an
incredible use for MDMA absolutely
getting through things as couples I
can't believe that it's not we're way
past PTSD into the end-of-life into
cancer into a CD into social anxiety and
autistic adults we did MDMA for people
with life-threatening illnesses anxious
about dying yeah so that's amazing that
it's branching off into all different
types of aspects of life and that's so
important to start testing that because
there's so much better we can do now
there's and I'm really glad that you're
laying the foundations for everyone else
to be able to do it better along the way
it's so funny that you also said that
you you know you wanna you want to have
this launch off as as your baby over the
last 35 almost 35 years launch off and
then you want to go to do psychedelic
psychotherapy for others yeah and give
that gift while other people take this
torture well that was actually my vision
for my life at age 18 in 1972 is when I
decided that I was going to be an
underground psychedelic therapist and
tried to bring back psychotherapy I
didn't really want to be an underground
psychedelic therapist I want to be legal
I want to do it I want to just have a
little office with the sign and not wear
please and boom it made you an
entrepreneur to move this all forward
now you find yourself yeah recently we I
gave a talk with one of the veterans
with one of our researchers and we have
a senior retired DEA official who's
working with us as a consultant awesome
whose son went into the military and got
PTSD and opened his father's eyes to
marijuana and no treatments for PTSD so
we just gave a talk at the International
Association of Chiefs of Police of to
simply it's like 10,000 people this was
in Orlando and it's such a
non-traditional audience yeah that
President Trump decided he would speak
to that audience to Wow so he came at
the last minute Wow and he spoke at the
exact same time that we had our panel
which was a bummer for us because one of
the people went to him but some people
still came to us and one of the persons
that came to us was a psychologist
working with police officers with
psychological problems including PTSD
that's you and he worked it out with his
chief and he is now going to come to our
training program in March Cree Nashville
to become a police psychologist able to
give them made a police officers Wow and
then now also go into firefighting into
veterans yes Wow yeah training veterans
therapists at work with the VA yes and
we've had several firefighters including
one that had PTSD from 9/11 yes we had
somebody that volunteered for our study
for phase 3 who has PTSD from Columbine
from the mass shooting yeah so there's
gonna be a lot of potential benefits
coming it's cool how people are latching
on and wanting to help work with you as
psychics as a psychotherapist across
their industry we have over 5,000 people
on a waiting list we want to know about
when we start our training program for
anymore 5,000 5,000 ther Harlan though
we have over 20,000 people who want to
know about being in the study 20,000
want to be 5,000 want to be therapists
in them yeah and we haven't even tried
to magnify these numbers you know a see
that's what's happening
there's a lot of attention coming to
this field okay now getting to this yeah
this well this this subject Gary
specifically is getting a lot of
attention around the world right now
it's the idea that it's really important
to do things like invest the appropriate
resources into into competition and
cooperation yet a space yeah so what is
our ideal sort of combination of those
two forces as companies try and
privatize their specific psilocybin
blends yeah meanwhile as we cooperate we
don't want to patent what the earth
produced for us yeah yeah so I think if
we look at the history of maps the
things that I've gotten the most
criticism for the first was accepting a
million dollar donation over four years
from Rebecca Mercer and the Mercer
family they were the ones that supported
Steve Bannon and president Trump and
they supported they owned cambridge
analytical which stole all the Facebook
data and also Breitbart but that was and
their rebecca's donation was limited to
veterans in our study yeah so that was
important bipartisan bridging but it got
a lot of criticism of that I like the
way you look at that is the bipartisan
bridging we're trying to bring humans
together yeah yeah totally and that's
the essence of democracy is you don't
agree on everything you find your areas
of agreement you work together and you
disagree on other things the other thing
that I got a lot of criticism for was
providing help or all of our information
all of our negotiation of FDA to new
SONA which is a non-profit group trying
to make psilocybin into a medicine for
the ocean but also to compass which is a
for-profit appeal so my view is as a
nonprofit people get tax deductions to
give us money we have an obligation to
the public and the public includes both
for-profit and nonprofit
and so I think there's a need for a
for-profit drug development in the
psychedelic space because that will
permit scaling I mean right now we are
there frustratingly stalled out we have
raised 27 million for phase 3 over the
history of maps we've raised over 60
million dollars in donations but we've
been struggling now to raise the nine
million we need to take phase three
empty maybe DSD to Europe and then what
about how do we set up thousands of
psychedelic clinics or help therapists
do that so there's a need for for-profit
but for-profit can be out of control
yeah and when you profit maximize to the
exclusion of everything else so we
started the maps public benefit
corporation yes which is a modification
of capitalism yes where you maximize
public benefit you do make a profit but
that's not your topmost goal your
topmost goal is public benefit and so we
have the for-profit public benefit
corporation but it has only one investor
which is the nonprofit all right so what
I'm saying to this is that we don't have
any patents we hired a patent attorney
to develop an anti patent strategy yeah
so that nobody could patent uses of MDMA
yeah just so they're all in the public
domain and so but people will try to
patent different things and that will
drive innovation and incentives and and
I think that's okay if they just
discover some new drug let's say that's
better than MDMA and somebody town did
it and they want to develop it in a
for-profit way I'm all for it yeah
you're right that will slowly move the
ball forward faster by allowing the
private players to play but preferably
as benefit corporations so that way
they're maximizing benefit and with the
psychedelics that we've been different
through earth to help heal humans and
and destroy these walls between us
rather than try and per maximize their
own profits and put out the
externalities on to other people
although the social costs other people
pay and the company makes the profit
yeah I think that's and I think if you
look at what's the main resistance
people have to the legalization of
marijuana it's the big alcohol and big
tobacco we're gonna get involved and
then maximize profit sell the kids do
all sorts of stuff and that's actually
happening I mean the beer companies the
the alcohol companies there's
buddies are buying into marijuana
companies you prefer cannabis infused
beverages and exist so yeah I think you
gotta be very careful because that mind
isn't being more that by the minds being
molded into the world and if we're going
to try and yeah and in deliver doses of
cannabinoids at young ages we have to be
very careful with what the long-term
effect of things like this are so we
can't just go for profit we got to go
for science research and development
take it slowly
let's move this inside bye everybody
from the hot tub we will read you'll
enjoy the inside
[Laughter]
oh isn't that beautiful yeah Wow
though there's the Chinese are over
right there
[Laughter]
boom we're back everyone from the hot
tubs super relaxing gonna have to make
it up that's a series of updates on
psychedelic studies and the from Rick's
hot tub I think it's a tradition it's a
good tradition Oh none of it where are
the interviews in hot tubs happening
around the world and we did in the
winter this time we did in January yeah
it's time last time I was in May so this
has much colder well this doesn't really
count because there was no snow it was
enough to do it while it's snowing why I
snow I don't know how good the cameras
will stand up to that we were ending our
conversation in the hot tub on
cooperation and competition yeah and how
the best sort of add the privatization
in to move things forward but make it
like a benefit corporation like you were
saying as well so yes so tell us again
this this this is kind of where people
are seeing the future yeah so we're how
else can we understand this in a way
that people can maybe get involved with
starting businesses as entrepreneurs
yeah oh yeah well there's gonna be
thousands of psychedelic clinics that
need to be established we're thinking at
maps that we're gonna have a network of
clinics but all the people that we
trained to do MDMA therapy for PTSD can
set up their own clinics so we're not
trying to monopolize anything and not
only that but they can innovate in a
sense so they the way that we're
negotiating with the FDA is called the
realms the risk evaluation and
mitigation strategy so it's a special
set of policies that are put into place
to address special risks because every
drug has or many drugs have special
risks so with psychedelics particularly
with mdma-assisted psychotherapy for
PTSD the treatment is not the drug it's
the drug assistance psychotherapy so the
only people that will be able to
prescribe it and the only people that
will be able to work with patients are
those that have been through our train
program to learn this in therapy and it
can only minister to under direct
supervision never as a take home drug so
that's why we'll have a psychedelic
clinics like nourishing and once people
have learned our method they're free to
innovate or modify and if they want to
yeah post approval but we think that
with the Maps clinics it'll use our
method and that'll ya know they'll get
this but other people could say alright
combine it with massage or I combined it
with yes I'm sort of guided imagery or
this or that so we want all sorts of
different kinds of therapeutic
approaches to flourish but I think that
as we look at this there's gonna need to
be all sorts of capital invested in
creating these thousands of clinics the
therapists are you know working to make
a living people need so also when we
think about the future of work and the
future of innovation and driverless cars
and things what are the things that
cannot be done by machines yeah a lot of
it like massage or a lot of things about
life therapy I mean there are a certain
kind of machine intelligence programs to
talk you know they pretended that our
therapists in a month but I think that
these kind of helping professions the
those are the kind of things that are
going to be least likely to be automated
out of existence the human connection
yeah and so we're going to be creating
jobs that are gonna be durable
you know automation and innovation in
that way yeah so I think that there is a
role for for-profit companies and people
to make livings helping other people
work through dramas and work through
relationship issues and we're through
eventually you know personal growth
these clinics will be centers where
people go for spiritual experiences yes
some of them we run by your local church
or your local synagogue will have their
own little psychedelic clinic that's
what this is a really awesome future
that you're painting for us you're
preparing us yeah in a bunch of
different ways so there's there's um you
were mentioning earlier that there's
there's five thousand therapists that
are ready you know want to get involved
in
in your processes of becoming psychosis
a psychotherapist and then there's
20,000 people waiting for the proper
decent first places like these clinics
been able to go and get treatments and
then your your even very intelligently
showing us part of the future with
automation is humans that actually can
you have the eye-to-eye he has to face
therapies and this is actually huge as
you see these thousands of potentially
clinics that are going to be showing up
in the next decade let's say that to get
involved in them is going through a
process of getting trained by you and I
love your formula you were talking about
the formula here the formulas so cool
because the formula is for now what
you've designed and you found to be most
effective for now and then there's gonna
be more and more dosage adjustments for
different sorts of eunuchs that are need
to be done with different stresses on
people's lives that they're trying to
break free from them and integrate etc
and also adding in massage or lighting
and yeah felicitations takes but the
other further complexity is that we're
talking about developing MDMA for PTC
others are about ibogaine for opiate
addition or so those I've been for
depression or ketamine for depression
but what we're really talking about its
economic psychotherapy yeah so in the
future people will get a series of
different experiences with different
psychedelic drugs and there will even be
opportunities to combine drugs like
we've done therapy you know underground
theory we have not done it but
underground therapists have done work
where they combine LSD with MDMA or LSD
with ketamine even or MDMA with ketamine
or the different kinds of combinations
like this also offer you know new kind
of therapeutic opportunities and I know
we'll see more likely we'll see
treatments where people go through a
sequence of different psychedelic drugs
probably generally starting with MDMA
because it's the most gentle it's the
easiest to work what if it's the least
distance from our normal price
yeah that then they could go into the
psilocybin or ghosty or Onalaska ripe
again or any number of things and the
fact that we're doing a study with MDMA
you know for PTSD there's a lot of
people that have dual diagnosis PTSD in
addiction and so a lot of it is the
trauma that drives people to addiction
but we will eventually have you know the
study in England I mentioned which is
death tour Ben Sasse ahem do you may for
alcoholism yeah there's gonna be all
sorts but then LSD has been really
effective for alcoholism so you start
with them do you may work on the trauma
then you help somebody kind of have this
mystical spiritual sense of connection
and there's different kinds of strength
people can draw from each of those kinds
of experiences yeah it's so cool that
you put the assets psychedelic
psychotherapy is that umbrella yeah and
there's all different kinds of
combinations that are going to evolve
out of it and then we'll see what's best
for what yeah yeah yeah the thing we
haven't really talked about is there's
an NGO project let's do it so the Zender
project is psychedelic harm reduction so
there's a lot of people that are you
know not waiting for medicalization that
are using psychedelics and events all
over the world and festivals that music
concerts at parties and there's a lot of
those people that are doing it for
recreation but then they they really say
I just want to have a good experiences
not the bad and then difficult stuff
comes up and they confuse that as being
bad and then they resist it and then it
gets worse so as part of our effort both
to to prepare the ground for
post-prohibition world but also to
reduce the kind of potential for
backlash that could come from you know
bad experiences with psychedelics we
have started the zendo project our first
effort actually was in 2001 at a
festival where we tried to and did
succeed him working with the organizers
with the medical people even with the
police and provided support for people
having difficult technology experiences
so that's what the Zenda project is it's
helping so sort of peer support yeah
where we have a few trained therapists
but we train other people and bringing
that for example we over the last two
years we've seen a thousand people who
have come to us but difficult over two
years two years a thousand four thousand
people yeah and we've trained over five
hundred helpers oh wow sinners exactly
most of them therapists but not all of
them yeah and so we're helping to try to
build into the culture even of the
recreational thing a therapeutic
understanding a spiritual mindset about
how suppressing and resisting is really
the more fruitless strategy yeah that
doesn't really solve the problem is sort
of prolongs the problem you need to help
people and that our big thing is you
know difficult is not the same as bad
yeah this is n-no project is now hope is
one of the sort of components that we
should see at all different types of
recreational use areas of psychedelics
yeah and that we are super helpful for
these experiences and and and again it's
almost as though we're we're now you're
laying again another piece of a
foundation outside of your you know your
B Corp and outside of I'm doing the
trials you're even in you know no
festivals and burning then one not to
help there so there's all different
places that Maps touches yeah with its
kindness with its heart with its open
and love I'm we we are very honored to
be sitting down with you and talking
about this again
an important way I think we can wrap is
by talking about how this all is
intertwined ah okay yeah because we have
so graciously been gifted with this
consciousness on this planet then we
evolved through time to get here here we
are all humans ever born and lived and
died on this rock together and we have
to figure out the unity
yeah and it comes from you were listing
all these experiences the flirtations
the meditations the religious the
spiritual the psychedelic there's all
acts love sex Roy has all rights yeah
yeah the transcending our own time and
space and then being a part of something
greater so that sort of feeling is the
most cohesive way forward yeah I want
you to tell us about your thoughts on
that
well I think so many people come back
with this idea that love is the essence
of the universe
I guess I'll share this story about the
most mystical experience of my life and
so it was at Esalen camping out oh well
we have this way you know from the last
time I asked yes I asked you what was
the most beautiful thing yeah I think
emotion yeah yeah that was gravity it
was gravity yeah yeah the kind of being
cradled in the arms of gravity
what's it gravity is this force that
pulls us together and there's a love
aspect to that and that was so beautiful
because that yeah yeah that was so good
that you said that one um okay here let
me phrase the question this way okay
yeah I think I have a good way to phrase
it
okay what's a take away a piece of
advice for young people and adults on
both that can inspire them towards that
sense of unity what can they better in
practice maybe well I think that for now
in the American context what we really
need to do is heal these partisan
divides and understand that you know
underneath the a lot of this
anti-immigrant and white nationalism of
a lot of the fears and anxieties that
Trump is trying to stir up in his base
that there are people there who we need
to reach out and
there's a better way that and also that
they're operating from a place of fear
and anxiety that the culture you know it
hasn't properly addressed all their
concerns you know the irony is that they
get motivated through fear and anxiety
to support policies that end up hurting
themselves more than helping them so I
never quite could understand why you
know the Affordable Health Care you know
white people didn't like that and it
turns out that actually the the most
anti-government sentiment is in areas
and states where people get the most
government assistance mmm because
there's this kind of sense of not
wanting to be dependent but then getting
angry whereas instead of seeing it as
necessarily how people you know bite the
end of feeds it so I think that what we
need to be doing is really listening in
a deeper level to the pain that's
motivating people to be separate yeah
and try to understand how we can work
through it and sometimes the the problem
is that people have to willingly let go
of their prejudices and anxieties you
can't force them to do it and the same
is true in a therapeutic setting yeah
and that's why we say that basically
people heal themselves we create a
support the drug primarily creates this
support for people to process difficult
emotions but they have to be willing to
do that and so it's our job to create a
context where people heal themselves so
we have to create a social context where
people who are different from us are not
so much judged but are held in a certain
way to to acknowledge their own
misgivings about some of the things that
they might be saying or thinking yeah so
I think it's that way and it's also like
one of the projects that we haven't
talked about is that I worked on it this
morning and I have to work
today is a psychedelic peacemaking yeah
so we have a project
Natalie Ginsberg Leo Roseman it's in
Israel and it's psychedelics for
peacemaking between Israelis and
Palestinians and they've just come back
from Israel a few days ago and there's
groups of Israeli Jews Israeli Arabs and
Palestinians that are doing ayahuasca
together Wow
kind of secretly you know are very
secretly but it's happening and many of
them have used MDMA yeah now they're
coming to these that's great it's
incredible thereby they're coming
together
they're coming together primarily for
healing yeah and so we're trying to
understand that but we're also trying to
do so they've just completed Natalie and
Leora interviews with roughly 36 people
half israelis leone half more Israeli
Arabs and Israeli and Palestinians
Israeli Jews and what their what we're
wanting to do is is create more
intentional settings for peacemaking yes
so not just healing but the healing
interpersonal healing inner tremor is
important to then healing interpersonal
yeah kind of a trauma yeah and I think
that that's the now these are not the
the zealots on either side that would
never talk to each other that they need
so these are the more progressive parts
but even then they've grown up in
cultures that demonize the other that
build fear for the other so even though
the most progressive people have a lot
of work to do to overcome their cultural
training and then we see it as like
training the trainer's these will be
people that will then go out and try to
work with groups that are a little bit
further on the margins towards hatred of
each other yeah and so I think that
that's really the kind of direction that
we need to be going in in general is
looking at those marginalized voices or
those people that we discount ourselves
and then trying to understand how they
got that way and what can we do at the
same time you know people have to be
willing to change and when they won't
and this is why I'm not a pacifist you
know we were talking before you have to
defend yourself you have to block them
in certain ways from being racist
but at the same time have compassion
because they are narrowing their own
frame of reference and they are
suffering underneath that so I think
that's the challenge and that's why when
I took an instrument meeting Rebecca
Mercer and that how wonderful that we
can have this large bridge yeah and so
when people would criticize me for that
I would say we're in the business of
building bridges not burning them yeah
why push people away like that right so
I think the other part is this and it
gets in the way back to the Zenda
project is that people do have fears of
psychedelics I mean that these drugs do
change consciousness they do require
letting go you have to be safe to do
that things come up that you weren't
ready for sometimes and there are a lot
of legitimate fears and anxieties that
people have about psychedelic drugs
about marijuana and we have to
acknowledge them while we move towards
public health rather than criminal
justice yes I couldn't just started
picturing how people over thousands of
years have been fighting about religion
and how that could yeah in maybe a
couple generations just be done I think
it could be well what they say is the
future is always here is the future is
already here it's just not evenly
distributed so I think in many places
there will be more of this recognition
that we're all together and I think if
in a couple generations we haven't
reached that point as a species we may
have destroyed the place yeah we've got
to get there and that's also very
interesting that this is now these
peaceful gatherings are going on around
the world in different groups that
fighting over religion or land for so
long yeah yeah and there's also studies
that we're not involved in but that I
think are really important are there's a
study at Johns Hopkins and NYU with
religious professionals from different
religions giving them psilocybin and a
therapeutic setting and so they're kind
of looking at the mystical looking at
the experiences that people from
different religions will have and these
are not just people these are like
ministers pastors people the
congregation Imams however and and so
they're there they're looking at what
kind of visions they have what kind of
experiences and what they're finding is
that it doesn't take people away from
their religion they just interpret their
religion in a more symbolic rather than
literalist way and it revitalizes their
appreciation for their own religion so
it's not gonna be everybody giving up
the past you know to one you know
uniform global religion that everybody
you know it's it's going to revitalize
all the separate religions
yeah so I think even though it's like
the unity and diversity the same way and
appreciate other people we're not the
same as them we're definitely gonna
celebrate our differences and at the
same time know that we're all together
yes yes now last question is what would
you say is one of the core driving
principles of your life fear fear a fear
of one year of doing nothing fear of the
irrational dominating so I think what
I've been able to do is turn fear into
an ally okay so what really motivated me
at age 18 to work on psychedelics was
fear first off I was educated about the
Holocaust as a young boy and that was
terrifying but you know people could
want to kill me and kill only for this
religion of my family that
nothing to do with I'm born into that
then a bunch of people would want to
kill me that was terrifying you know
luckily I was born in America in 53
after that was over so I was raised
there that was in the past but it was
the fear of that and then not too long
after I started really wrestling with
that was the fear of the Russians and of
the Cuban Missile Crisis and hiding
under my desk at school I'm teaching you
that was terrifying
yeah and then became the Vietnam War now
all of a sudden it's my old country
wanted to send me to work for reasons
that did not make sense to me so I felt
that that people are evolving but we're
still fundamentally more irrational than
rational and that that kind of
irrationality coupled with the brilliant
technology that we have is destroying
the world and could work in you know
mass disruption mass murder so it was
the fear of the irrational that and that
the view that psychedelics brought the
irrational to the surface that brought
the unconscious to the surface 10 Groff
the world's leading LSD researchers said
that LSD is to the study of the mind
with the telescope is to astronomy and
the microscope is the biology so I felt
like here was a tool that could get us
to these deep levels that are destroying
us and so I'd say it's fear that has
driven me this whole way that made it so
that I would never give up but but also
propelled me in really healthy ways so
it wasn't debilitating fear because I
think I grew up in so it was so are so
lucky because I grew up with all the
advantages that you could have to think
that you could make a difference so I
grew up in America at the time of the
maximum strength of America in the whole
world and American exceptionalism which
I believe
somehow I don't believe it anymore but
that American people were essentially
better than other people and that
therefore that's why we were leading the
world but I grew up with that sense of
confidence from America having won world
war two and were the most powerful
country then I was a male not only that
I was the first born male child in my
family so I had that then I'm white at
the time when white was really important
and I'm Jewish
with the chosen people and my family was
financially well-off with my dad as a
doctor and my grandfather having run a
successful business and so I had all the
the kind of psychological advantages to
make me think that maybe I could make a
difference and all the support from my
family and then I think gave me the
ability to not be overwhelmed by the
fear the the fear is the driving thing
but instead of it being overwhelming me
it was kept in a certain kind of balance
yeah and that's what I'm saying but the
other big thing I'd say is that early on
because it seemed like in 1972 when I
decided this one was a team that and
psychedelics had been squashed and
saying about research had been squashed
it was a massive undertaking to try to
think about bringing you back yeah and
so what I realized at the time was that
if I would only be happy if it worked
that I might never be happy and I would
always be waiting for something in the
future to make me happy so that I had to
move from outcome to process the process
yet to the journey to the journey to the
struggle and so if I struggled during
the day and the world was still the same
I can still be happy yeah I tried my
best and that was satisfying and I think
that was the the key thing that really
helped me to not get burned out just
thought that it looks like there may be
no success I mean when I met my wife
you know one of the things that she said
is that she really appreciated people
who were working on lost causes
hmm so she thought at the time bringing
back psychics Chris was a lost cause so
I love this yeah it's kind of like no
more lost cause kind of thing yeah now
she had done similar kind of you know
idealistic things so I think that when
you work out what could potentially be a
lost cause but you can get satisfaction
from the daily struggles that's the key
to longevity and also that you mentioned
with fear there's something that all of
us experience that we only have these
25,000 days alive and that we get to
pick whatever we do everything the
moment is so important to striving to be
our best in the world and so to have
some sort of a little fire under our
butt that kicks us up and gets us going
on that thing is it's so crucial the
other advantage that I had is the access
to psychedelics you know we are now
living in a time of the world that's
never been in existence before okay I
began from Capone from western Africa
yeah we can do I begin ayahuasca from
the Amazon oh yeah we can do ayahuasca
LSD from the laboratory yeah we can do
that and be away from the laboratory
mushrooms from the ground from thousands
we can do so we have access to these
tools that have been fundamentally
transformative in my own personal life
yeah and it's to those tools in the
context of this therapeutic spiritual
understanding that's also really
enabling me because I know deep down
they work yes they're valuable they've
got all sorts of challenges but there's
something to it they've all sort of
brought a sense of unity the microscopes
or biological telescopes for astronomy
and then psychedelics for our minds so
they've all sort of brought a sense of
the unity these are to us yeah the other
thing just in terms of
raising I mean as I said we've raised
over 60 million dollars but if I had to
tell a story to people what we're trying
to do it would have been you know which
is what I do it would be very difficult
unless people have had their own
experiences as well so they can relate
to the story yeah so because things have
been so widespread there are and many
many people have had these
transformative experiences with them yes
we can tell a story of what we're doing
but then it resonates with people all
over because now we're doing the
psychedelics because I dinner parties
are on theater night and whatnot and
we're starting to share the stories yeah
making it popular to be talking about
how if not even popular safe say in a
way Zia and popular and yeah and then I
can slowly destroy the walls yeah and
that's why I'm so glad to be interviewed
by you and to do this because it's
really another way of so it used to be
that I thought her main or it used to be
that our main obstacle obstacles were
regulatory that we could not get
permission at all then the main
obstacles were money how do we raise the
money to do it and we've managed to do
that in large part and that then the the
big challenge was well there's a bunch
of these underground Rahzel it's you
know but how do we train more therapists
so now we're figuring out how to do that
and so the last and final obstacle I
would say or challenge is public
education yeah is building support and
that's where it this is so crucial yeah
my gosh these obstacles that you're just
going through one after the other and
boom now you're a few 33 years later we
love Maps Maps toward everyone go check
out the link in the bio also the the
trials that are going through right now
keep an eye on the maps has on their
news so many different videos are up now
and articles are written and with maps
and in the news and yeah also just the
trial design now we're gonna be taking
these combinations of both the trial
design and rolling with them across
other psychedelics as well as getting
these traumas that have been built up in
society and helping us integrate them
and move forward and the
sure looks like these clinics yeah
that's it's such interesting stuff to be
able to talk to you for round two here
you're home in Boston thank you so much
for yeah I'm gonna the show Rick well I
look forward to our next hot tub
interview discussion and and the great
thing is is that hopefully by then there
will be more breakthroughs and yeah and
with people like you and maps you know
you're at them you know a million bucks
a month in spending now on making I'm
pushing the ball forward and that's so
crucial let's get that to 10 million oh
I'm sure let's do it let's do it let's
get there we can do it and and we okay
well we will do it the Millennials and
Gen Z are coming in and they have a
strong yeah drive for this potential
indoor world yeah well they know the
risks that are going on out there of not
of not doing it's an existential ones
yeah yeah much love everyone thank you
so much for tuning and we greatly
appreciate it go and check out the links
below support maps please also support
us to continue doing cool things like
coming to Boston and making these
awesome interviews of different global
leaders links are below also give us
your thoughts in the comments below we'd
love to hear from you about the episode
and your thoughts about all of this you
can also reach to it's ask maps at maps
org if you have any questions yeah and
also if you'd like to potentially get
involved in any of the of the of the
trials and processes of any sorts and
bring this around the world so please
get involved yeah yeah okay cool much
love everyone Thank You social team also
go and build your destiny everyone
manifest your dreams answer the world go
and build go create we love you so much
and we will see you soon well that's
mean ending wow so much love for you